did you know that two out of every three guys will
experience some form of male pattern borders by
the time they're 35 yeah i did for me it was more
like 25. i wish keeps have been around when i was
younger because advancements in science meant
that there are now treatments that can come at
the symptoms of hair loss so you can keep the hair
that you have look it's too late for me my hair is
not coming back but you don't have to be like me
you can stop your hair loss early thanks to keeps
keeps offers generic versions of the only two
fda approved drugs for treating hair loss so you
might have tried them before but never at a price
this low that's right if you were thinking uh some
sort of medicine simon it's gonna be expensive
well don't worry keep starts at just ten dollars
a month how does it work well for one thing
there's no need to visit a doctor's office just
schedule a quick online consult a little bit
later discreet package gonna arrive at your door
so if you're noticing that you're losing your hair
it's not a problem that's gonna fix itself guys
do something about it for a limited time go to
keeps.com forward slash biographics or you just
click the link in the description below to save
50 of your first order and now today's video
legend has it that on the 20th of june 1941 a
team of soviet archaeologists opened the tomb
of a mighty central asian ruler whose
ruthlessness and skill in battle was
second only to genghis khan his tomb bore
the inscription when i rise from the dead
the world shall tremble when the archaeologists
located the coffin they read an even more ominous
threat whoever opens my tomb shall unleash an
invader more terrible than i two days later
hitler launched operation barbarossa against
the ussr the largest land invasion in history
the legend goes that when the fearsome warlord
was again sealed in his tomb the soviets won at
stalingrad this archaeological expedition actually
took place but i wouldn't bet on the accuracy of
any other details but this story captures the
fierce reputation of today's protagonist amir
tamur the lane also known as tamerlane abandoned
a mercenary of mongol origin he rose through the
ranks becoming the most powerful ruler in the 14th
century islamic world eventually he conquered an
empire stretching from delhi to the mediterranean
in the words of historian beatrice forbes manns
timur could boast a stature bigger than life
and a charisma bordering on the supernatural
before we get into the birth and rise
of today's protagonist let me give you
a little bit of context after the death of genghis
khan the mongol empire was split between four of
his descendants his second son chagatai inherited
a vast territory in central asia which became
known as the chaga hired carnate this policy
included most of modern day's bekistad kazakhstan
parts of mongolia and china's jinyang province
the carnate's economy was based on thematic
herding and was less outwardly aggressive than its
northern neighbor the golden horde this wasn't out
of the kindness of their hearts but because of
constant internal strife and division eventually
the chag had eyed carnate fragmented into
several entities the largest being the powerful
moghelestan in the east and the less formidable
trans-soxiana in the west in this divided land
a boy was born in 1336 a.d his birthplace
was kesh modern-day sharbs arbs in uzbekistan
his father was called tarakai a minor nobleman of
the nomadic barlis tribe these were a sunni muslim
turkisized mongol group once allied to chagatai
a birth he was called timur meaning iron a name
which carried an omen of strength tenacity and
conquest timur and family never had a place to
call home following nomadic habits they roamed the
steps south of the capital samacans looking for
the best pastures for their livestock the young
timur soon grew tired of looking after grazing
animals his parents were not clan leaders but the
barlow society allowed upward mobility for tough
youngsters who were handy with a composite
bow especially if shot from horseback timur
displayed a clear talent for violence in action
a talent which he put to fruition by stealing
horses and sheep from neighboring clans soon he
added banditry to cattle rustling on his cv and
built a following of like-minded young warriors
at the age of 21 in 1357 timur trained his gang
into a mercenary outfit and entered the service of
tug luck tamar the khan of nearby kashgar shortly
afterwards the ruler of transaxiana amir khasgan
died tuglaque took the opportunity to invade and
in 1361 he conquered samakand the young timur must
have played an important role in the conquest as
he was appointed chief advisor to turlock's son
elias koha from shepard to bandit to minister
aged only 25. not bad but also not enough timur
was not happy to play second fiddler to elias
koya so he forged an alliance with the ruler of
balker modern-day afghanistan the emir or prince
hussein the friendship was consolidated when timur
married hussein's sister the two bros kicked off a
rebellion against two gluck and ilyas which did
not go as planned the two fled to the region of
kharasan southwestern afghanistan where
timur resumed his mercenary activities
in 1363 during a skirmish with enemy horsemen an
arrow pierced his right hand and knocked him off
his horse as a result he lost his little and
ring fingers and suffered a permanent injury
to his right leg from then on he developed a
lifelong limp he also acquired the nickname
that would make him immortal timur ilenko timur
the lame better known in the west as tamerlane
at this stage one may define timur as an exiled
upstart with a prominent physical disability this
may have been a clear disadvantage especially in
territories spawned from the mongol empire which
valued physical prowess and nobility of blood
only descendants from genghis and their relatives
could aspire to the title of khan but tamar's
ambitions knew no boundaries in 1364 he spotted
an opportunity to continue his climb tugle could
died and it was time to settle scores with his son
ilyas timur and amir hasan attacked transoxiana
conquering the entire region by 1366. as it
happened before timur was the power in the
shadows while hussein had assumed titular power
as khan establishing a new capital in balka but
the relationship between the two brothers-in-law
started to sour the khan had grown arrogant
imposing a despotic rule and amassing the wealth
of his subjects according to some sources he may
have even kidnapped one of timo's sisters to join
his harem as a big no-no of course if you fancy
your best friend's sister it's probably better
to marry her but more realistically the last draw
was when hussein refused to pay his soldiers wages
in the spring of 1370 tamu started to plot
building alliances with other military leaders
soon he commanded a formidable army and went
on the attack hussein's forces were beaten time
and again until timur besieged baloch hussein's
loyalists fought desperately trying two sorties
which inflicted heavy casualties on their enemies
but timur pressed on and a defeated hussein
sought refuge in the mosque of balak offering
all of his riches in exchange for his life
according to contemporary sources tamur shed some
tears at the sight of his old friend begging for
mercy but his allies bathed for revenge and killed
the khan in cold blood it seems then that timur's
tears dried up very quickly as he collected an
imposing war booty and married four of hussein's
widows one of them was saray descendant of genghis
khan with this new found legitimacy tamar restored
the capital and samacand and declared himself
sovereign of the chaghadai incarnate restorer
of the mongol empire still he styled himself
as amir rather than khan honoring the central
asian traditions but titles meant little to the
pragmatic leader he knew that true power rested
on the saddles and bows of his unstoppable
army and he was ready to build an empire
for the following 10 years timur fought endless
campaigns conquering areas corresponding
to today's southern kazakhstan western
uzbekistan and the xinjiang province in china
even joined the golden horde in their fight
against the russians occupied moscow and then
he took on the lithuanians at poltava ukraine many
of these campaigns may have been dictated by the
opportunity to pillage some sizeable loot but
timur was a capable long-term strategist his end
goal was to consolidate power along the silk road
the wealthiest commercial route linking europe
to the far east by controlling it he would ensure
a consistent income to fund his expeditions
he appeared to achieve victory without much effort
but of course the military prowess of his armies
did not happen by chance timur's horses were a
composite bunch with soldiers joining from every
corner of central and east asia but the corps
the elite came from the steps of transoxyana
these men made up an army some 140 000 strong
disciplined and staunchly loyal timur's almost
supernatural charisma ensured they would follow
him everywhere they fought mainly on horseback
and their weapon of choice was the composite
bow which they mastered from an early age
by their early teens each nomadic horseman
was able to shoot an arrow every five seconds
hitting targets at 60 meters distant these highly
mobile units were complemented by well-trained
infantry specialized in siege warfare when meeting
an enemy in a pitched battle timur eschewed the
traditional formation which included a center
wings and a reserve instead he split his army
into seven divisions three at the front three in
support and a reserve to the rear this allowed him
to throw in fresh horses and riders when needed
wearing out the enemy defensive lines furthermore
amir realized the limitations of his army he
knew they were good at conquering and less so
at holding territories therefore he concentrated
occupation forces in rich agricultural lands and
was happy to let go of the less profitable steps
one such land full of riches was persia which
the conqueror targeted in 1383. the ruling ilknid
dynasty was extinct and too many competitors vied
to fill the power vacuum taking advantage of
this civil stripe tamur invaded from the north
capturing herat its inhabitants suffered horrific
treatment which was to serve as an example for
other cities tibor's army plundered all treasurers
leveled ancient landmarks and slaughtered many of
the defenders rumors of such ruthlessness spread
across the country and several cities like tehran
surrendered without a fight others like
ishvahan fought back only to regret it
later timur ordered a massacre of ishifan citizens
and their skulls were piled up in morbid towers
several meters high by 1385 all of eastern persia
had fallen the land was depleted of its riches as
well as of its most talented inhabitants the emir
deported artists architects intellectuals and
artisans to samacans where they would contribute
to the building of an imperial capital in tamir's
vision the city was to be the beating heart of
the islamic world as well as the cultural hub of
central asia samakand was to become a tangible
testament to timur's ambition to be recognized
both as the defender of islam and the restorer of
genghis khan's greatness and the track record of
the lame prince was indeed worthy of his role
model between 1386 and 1394 he was unstoppable
southern iran iraq mesopotamia and the caucasus
all bent the knee timmer's campaign to control
azerbaijan was conducted alongside takatamesh
khan of the golden horde the two allies though
soon dissented over who should control the
silk road as we know by now timur was not above
turning against old friends and a new war was on
initially dr thomas had the upper hand invading
trans-oxiana and even besieging samacand however
he was repulsed and timur chased him back into
the russian steps in 1391 the golden horde was
defeated on the konderche river but they returned
with vengeance four years later the two
armies clashed again in april of 1395
over the terrick river northern caucasus this
time many of tokitamish's generals defected to the
other side and timur's victory was decisive during
this campaign the unstoppable conqueror raised the
ground the cities of sarai azov and astrakhan as
his attention was diverted persia revolted against
the emir but the revenge was swift and utterly
brutal more towers of skulls obscured the sun
in september of 1398 timur set his sights on india
in his view the sultan of delhi mahmoud tuglach
was too tolerant of his hindu subjects he
amassed an army of 90 000 men and crossed
the indus river attacking delhi on december 17th
mack would put up a strong defense by deploying
dozens of war elephants covered in chain mail and
topped by wooden towers but timur had a plan he
had the battlefield covered with spiked iron cow
troops which wounded and diverted the attacking
beasts then he unleashed a charge of riderless
camels each carrying a load of blazing hay the
terrified elephants stampeded their own troops
sowing confusion and panic the wondrous city of
delhi soon became another wasteland of ruins
the following year timur looked to the west
to settle accounts with the ottoman empire and
the mamluk sultanate of egypt guilty of having
seized mongol lands in anatolia modern-day turkey
the confrontation began with some serious trash
talk tomorrow to the ultimate sultan baazeed thy
obedience to the qur'an in waging war against the
infidels is the sole consideration that prevents
us from destroying thy country bezid replied
what are the arrows of the flying tartar
against the scimitars and battle axes of my firm
and invincible janissaries well i guess we'll
see won't we the timmerid steamroller galloped
westward storming aleppo damascus and baghdad
in 1401 20 000 of its citizens were slaughtered
after setting camp for the winter timur reached
anatolia in the early summer of 1402. he first
laid siege the town of sivis promising not to shed
a drop of blood if the inhabitants surrendered
and they did three thousand of them then were
buried alive so technically demur kept his promise
the next challenge was buyers its main army of
85 000 men the two forces squared off at ankara
on the 28th of july timur had managed to turn many
ottoman vassals to his side outnumbering his foe
almost two to one but baazid knew how to fight a
defensive battle he deployed his infantry along
a stream on hilly terrain thus protected
the infantry could raise a shield wall
shielding the cavalry units from temur's attacks
seeing the futility of the initial charges tamur
decided to wear out the opponents with a stratagem
he had a creek diverted denying ottoman horses and
their riders from access to water the demoralized
horsemen were ultimately scattered by a charge
of war elephants which tamora had imported from
delhi the elite janissaries now without mounted
support were easy pickings for tomorrow's
heavy cavalry attacking their flanks but
bayazid inspired his surrounded men to fight on
until nightfall he then attempted to break out
at the encirclement but was captured by his enemy
the sultan was brought back to samacant where he
suffered a humiliating captivity at the hands
of timur who allegedly used him as a footstool
the ottomans had thus lost not only their leader
but 40 000 of their finest soldiers the power
vacuum in the ottoman empire resulted in a civil
war to the delight of western european powers
always weary of the ottoman thread the kings
of england france and castile sent messages
to timur congratulating him on his victory the
castilians even sent an ambassador to samacand
roy gonzalez de clavio claudio gave a vivid
account of tamur's court and exotic grandiosity
he was especially impressed by the amir's 15
palaces many of which could be disassembled
and moved when necessary he also described how
the supposed defender of the islamic faith was
a heavy drinker who organized lavish feasts every
night when one guest showed up late to one of his
parties punished him by piercing his nose like
a pig after clavio departed in november 1404
the ageing tomorrow prepared for what would be
his last expedition this time on the receiving end
would be ming china the mir had had a bone to pick
with the ming since 1395 when their emperor had
sent a message describing himself as lord of the
realms of the face of the earth and treating timur
as a subordinate he retaliated by detaining the
emperor's envoys when more messengers came looking
for them he also had them put in jail timur's
plan was to get rid of the arrogant emperor and
replace him with the wan dynasty descendants of
kublai khan the usual careful planner this time
committed a huge mistake good sense would dictate
initiating military campaigns in the spring to
take advantage of the good weather and plentiful
pastures for the war horses but timur set off in
december 1404 at the head of 200 000 troops his
astrologers had seen good omens in the stars but
the weather begged to disagree frosty climber
made the trek increasingly difficult for the army
whilst crossing the seer daya river uzbekistan
the once undefeated leader fell ill possibly as
a consequence of the cold the scourge of central
asia probably had wished for a glorious death in
battle but in february of 1405 age 69 timur
died of natural causes during his decades
of military successes the prince had failed
to create a functioning government structure
power was almost always centered around him
with no trusted lieutenant to take his place
and inspire the troops the expedition melted away
the two hundred thousand soldiers marched back to
samakant timur's body embalmed in oils and laid
an ivory coffin was buried in a splendid mausoleum
six centuries later the legacy of timur
ylang is controversial to say the least
driven by ambition and skill a disabled
cattle rustler and mercenary had defeated
some of the most powerful nations in
asia in the middle east assembling
a large empire his actions in anatolia weakened
the ottomans long enough for the byzantine empire
to survive 50 more years and his defeat of the
golden horde allowed for the expansion of russia
lithuania and poland but while in power he focused
mainly on destruction and conquest some estimates
place his death toll at 17 million about five
percent of the global population at the time
his inattention to political matters eventually
left his empire at the mercy of foreign invaders
as his line of succession was not clear his last
surviving son and his grandsons fought each other
for dominance losing the western half of the
empire nonetheless his timaru dynasty survived
for yet another century while samacand flourished
as a center for the arts literature and science a
later descendant babur took control of kabul
and later delhi founding mughal dynasty and
i'll leave the last word to you wisdom a great
ruler whose actions and influence had a huge
impact on the geopolitics of eurasia or maybe
you agree with military historian david nicole
who argued timur might have been a great soldier
but in purely historical terms he could be seen
as the greatest bandit of all times so i really
hope you found this video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button below don't
forget to subscribe and thank you for watching